and so it
looks like a three nothing lead because
this happens
with point five to play
but that was just enough time for the
wraps
but they put taco ball in to guard the
unbuckled jump
and nobody's near ogi and inoby
knocks it down what in the world is
jaylen brown doing
we're in the zone i don't understand why
you would be in the zone
the three beat you why in the world
would you be a zone that's that's not
smart
yeah you up two you don't let somebody
get a three against a zone that don't
make any sense jack
it gets it off
just in time i don't know why taco falls
in the game right there
i don't understand why you would be
playing a zone jack i mean
you up too you're not it's not a tie
game but you mentioned this earlier with
taco 4 being the game just made
it made an easier pass yeah i mean but i
don't understand why you would play a
zone in that situation i think the
subject was like a do-over on that one
the raptors as we said were down 10 at
the half their 17th
win when they trail at the half they're
17 and 16.
their fourth one point win in the
celtics fourth
one point loss of the season toronto 104
103. here's what they were talking about
after the game
you showed no emotion after you hit the
shot like how do you how did you
stay so cool after such a big part oh
look because when i shot i expected to
make it
so like i don't shoot trying to mess but
every shot
just get the ball told you and he made
it that's what it was about
get that get it to one of my teammates
that i truly believe in
and um that's what it's about man just
get it to my guy i believe in him and
like i said give og his flowers tonight
man
we just again weren't catching any
breaks and the ball wasn't going in
and you know the ball was bouncing funny
and it was just like man
to reach in and to reach in and find
that
gutsiness for that second half and find
an
a way even though it was very fortunate
finding a way
i'm not sure that doesn't rank right up
there with our gutsiest performances so
that was just a
disgrace at the end of the game that was
just terrible
you know no way we should have lost that
game
you know i take responsibility for that
not just that play but
you know a lot of the plays before just
needed one stop
to win the game
[Music]
for 23 minutes at 59 and a half seconds
of the second half
o.g annanoby had not attempted a shot
with a half a second to go he wins the
game
from deep and saved the raptors season
he definitely say to raptor seasons
i'm a big brass stevens fan i think he's
a great coach but tonight i think this
loss is on him
i think he left his dogs out too long
and let toronto get their
their feet under them and once they got
going they were rolling
and then i also think to go zone at the
end of the game that that made no sense
taco fall should have never been on the
floor
you're up two points if you're up three
you go zone to protect against the three
i understand
but to go this zone right now it's too
much gray area
and og made them pay how about the pass
by kyle lowry chuck
well the pass was fantastic but i think
the password made it easier because taco
fall
uh was over on him so he had to guess
you know
he he can't see because if you look at
the play tacos going back and forth
he's not actually all over the ball like
he should be he's jumping in lanes watch
this here
he he he moves too much
why see he goes down he goes back up
so this is this is just a wide open pass
listen kid just made a hell of a shot
but listen i agree with draymond i don't
understand why you're up to while you're
playing a zone
that kind of forces the team to shoot a
three if you play on the zone
but it's a great pass and a hell of a
shot
but uh dre said something else earlier
tatum was awful tonight
and you have to get a hail mary to win
the game
you cannot feel good and uh jaylen
brown's right
toronto won the game but the celtics
they blew that game yeah but i mean
this obviously gives the raptors new
life um well that's only if they win the
next game if they go down 3-1
that's listen that was a miracle well we
just saw a team come back from three one
two yeah but this thing
relax relax we just did we just saw a
team come back from 3-1
i know that's not the thing but toronto
is
toronto is very much alive now after
winning that game they're alive over the
hill mary
they didn't play great boston didn't
play great either but when you're a team
and you're supposed to beat another team
you've got to put them away you can't
give them chances because what if jason
tatum don't play good the next game then
now you're looking at a 2-2 series so
they're going to be very upset i think
they're going to come
out with much more energy of the next
game but they definitely
you know let this one get away yeah i
want to give kyle lowry credit
he battled him and fred van vliet they
were awesome tonight
now my my the young man sayakam they got
to get him going somehow
no no no he got to get himself going
he's a superstar remember
see i didn't see what you should do i
said it you didn't know he he got to get
himself going i said
he was an all-star shaq well he got to
get himself going hey but here's the
thing though
wait what shaq just just hit that see
y'all come have 14 points that second
half though
and when you like you said when you got
a chance to put a team away you have to
do that
he had 14 points now he going into this
next game feeling good
that can be trouble for boston i mean i
think i'm averaging 25 26. oh he got it
yeah but when you're the number one guy
you're supposed that's that's what i'm
saying i didn't say
see shaq i didn't joke superstar
all-star there's a difference between an
all-star and a superstar
they're like night and day a big
difference a big difference and he
listen he got to play good he can't be
giving me 14 points
i mean van and kyle laurie
they battled their butts off tonight
they were fantastic
but your best player always has to be
your best player if you're going to win
toronto now 34 for 120
from three-point range in the series
they were 13 for 40
in this game but they win it 104 103.
oh yeah the glove one of my favorite
people that was the point
i just i was going to let you fill in
the blank at home but i just want you to
know
deep trouble yeah so it worked
i appreciate i appreciate you listening
at home